and wired reports on questions swirling
around Facebook over that video that
shows the killing of an Ohio man we've
been talking about this morning police
are now hunting for Steve Stephens for
the killing yesterday of Robert Godwin
senior facebook says in a statement this
this is a horrific crime and we do not
allow this kind of content on Facebook
and are in touch with law enforcement
emergencies when there are direct
threats to physical safety CBS News
contributor Nicholas Thompson is editor
and chief of wired and joins us now from
San Francisco Nick it's good to see I'm
sorry it's for this terrible this story
is heartbreaking and horrifying at the
same time I can't imagine what it's like
for the Godwin family looking at that
video so help us understand the policy
as it stands now at Facebook and do you
think that this incident could now
change the game I think it's entirely
possible that this incident could change
the game the way it works right now at
Facebook is that when something goes
live it's not filtered or stopped before
it goes up people watch it and if they
flag it and say this is objectionable
content then it goes to people who work
for facebook who can then work to
possibly remove it but it's a really
complicated issue because sometimes
violence can be uploaded by the
perpetrator and sometimes it can be
uploaded by people watching trying to
prevent it so it's a very hard thing for
facebook to sort out even though your
three hours Nick is that a long time
it's a very long time it's longer than
you would think you would have thought
that this could have been taken down
faster it may have been because it was a
Sunday it may have been because it
wasn't flagged quickly enough but that
absolutely should have been taken down
much more quickly your magazine wired
reports that Facebook has resisted using
algorithms that could prevent this type
of video and content from being shared
why are they resisting it well there are
a lot of complicated issues at hand one
of course is the nature of the platform
right when Mark Zuckerberg created he
said he wanted everything to be as raw
and visible visceral as possible you
wanted people to feel like they could
share anything and that's good for the
most part until something something like
this happens so what Facebook has to do
is they have to decide how much of sort
of how much filtering they want to do
before something goes alive and how much
they want to do afterwards when you
filter something that goes up there are
issues that are raised to free speech
and there are issues that are raised
sometimes because videos can be helpful
right if you think about the video that
was posted yesterday and
imagine it hadn't been shot by the
perpetrator but had been shot by someone
witnessing who wanted to use the live
video feeding as a way to try to stop it
that's an entirely different case but
it's the exact same video that's why
these issues are complicated as
Facebook's philosophy towards this been
evolving at all Nick yeah absolutely
Facebook's philosophy towards its
responsibilities has absolutely been
evolving in the very beginning Mark
Zuckerberg thought of it it's just a
platform and everything goes out there
and we don't really have a
responsibility for what happens on it
now Facebook is taking it much more
seriously insane wait we're more of a
more of a publisher we have to be more
engaged in it what I think will happen
now if Facebook will have to a look at
their algorithms to try to understand
whether this can be stopped and be think
about the culture there is a real
culture of violence that has perpetrated
itself inside a video sharing and social
media platforms and can that be changed
the decisions that platforms make really
do shape the culture in the way people
use it and there may have been decisions
Facebook could have made at the
beginning or they can make now to limit
this kind of behavior alright Nick
Thompson thank you much very much for
being with us this morning thank you